The ovaries
are the female reproductive glands.
They consist of three types of cells:
epithelial,
germ,
and stromal.
When the cells in the ovaries
grow abnormally,
they develop into tumors
that can be noncancerous or cancerous.
If cancerous tumors
are not detected early,
the cancer cells can spread
from the ovaries
throughout the pelvic region
and continue to spread
to the abdominal area and other organs.
Determining the stage of ovarian cancer
is very important
in developing a treatment plan.
At stage one, cancer is limited
to one or both of the ovaries.
In stage two, ovarian cancer extends
to the pelvis area.
In stage three,
ovarian cancer has spread
to the abdominal region.
In stage four, ovarian cancer extends
into the liver,
or to locations
beyond the abdominal area.
Ovarian cancer treatment
typically includes
surgery,
chemotherapy,
radiation therapy,
or a combination of therapies.
[no sound]